is it helpful for someone to say oh
you're an actor you know who you look
just like and then you're like well even
if it's a compliment or maybe someone
you're thinking okay whatever but do you
feel if that's helpful for the outside
world to tell an actor that they look
just like another actor um I mean I
think it is in a way as much as a lot of
actors are insecure about that because
you know you do have to know how people
perceive you it doesn't mean you have to
try to pander to what people want from
you because I do think as an actor it's
important to take chances and take risks
and you know like follow your instincts
but at the same time you have to I think
you have to know how people perceive you
before you try and challenge that
because if you don't know how they
perceive you how are you gonna challenge
that you know like you gotta you gotta
because I've been told I look like
Robert Pattinson and whether that's a
good or a bad thing I think it's
important to know that because if you
don't know you know that's a lot of talk
about type in Hollywood right and I
think it can be quite limiting but even
so we still have to be aware of it so
because I mean if you're a heavyset man
you want to be James Bond and you think
you can change that and you think you
can challenge people's perception of
chance bond go ahead but in order to do
that you have to know that people will
not look at you and think that you're
James Bond so you have to be aware of
your type before you challenge your type
you do have to be aware of how people
perceive you it's like they don't say
you can break the rules but you have to
know the rules before you break them so
you don't even necessarily have to
follow the rules but you have to know
them right or in order to change the
system you have to be a part of the
system but maybe that's a different side
yeah I think in a way yeah so do you
remember when a casting director or
someone said oh this is your type and
how did you feel about it and then did
you want to challenge it uh-huh
me Robert Pattinson that's not a bad
that's not a bad no I think when did
people start saying that to me I think
like junior high school already people
were saying that about me
mm-hmm and I can see that yeah but you
still have your own look but did you did
you feel I
one of the Chasen I don't want it I mean
I I think yeah I think I felt that I had
some people say I look like Brando which
didn't bother me one bit sore no yeah
yeah and so I was aware of that and I
think it was I was aware that with my
look and with my build and with my
height that I think people could see me
as a kind of a young fresh face
California guy which is fine you can't
be too picky as a young person but I
wanted to kind of break that in order to
challenge that you really gotta know
what you're doing cause you really gotta
be good if you're gonna break people's
perception of your physical look like
you really got to bring that essence of
what you want with you and trying to
think of what else could set people how
to look like Brando that at drama school
I don't think they cast me as Outsiders
very often which disappointed me I must
admit like right the cast me there's a
lot of kings and princes which is fine I
was thinking myself I don't really know
if that's me unless it's a weird King
like a King George the third type of
thing so you knew that people considered
you extremely attractive and you okay
would guess okay well but but you wanted
something with maybe more depth to it
that wasn't just like oh he's a pretty
boy you wanted something that will have
maybe a dark side or a complicated side
- yeah it's not that attractive can't be
have depth to it but I like to Ryan
Gosling is an actor who really speaks to
me he's very good-looking he's very
handsome but up until a couple films
recently he didn't he never chose
typical leading man roles I mean there
was a notebook but when he was you but
even then with a notebook he doesn't
really play it like a typical handsome
guy you can tell he's a bit of a
sensitive kind of person and there's a
little bit of like kind of uh I think
something he's trying to prove with that
character and then but if you look at
after the notebook you know because he
could have just been this this romantic
leading man but he chose films like Half
Nelson repaid a Coke addicted teacher
Lars and the real girl like because he's
just beautiful man but he he wears ugly
sweaters in that movie and like stupid
beanies and he he's so disconnected that
he beat he has a sex doll that he
marries and is in love with right and
you know or I'm sorry yeah Blue
Valentine he's a just as this
working-class dude or just a product of
divorce and and I think he just really
he challenged his type for sure and and
drive as well he's just this autistic
seeming driver right so when you were
told what your type was did you find
different ways where you thought okay
I'd like to work around it when I do an
audition or even what I'm cast for I
want to have my own way about it that's
not just this one-dimensional pretty
character but I want to have it be
complicated layers where you go there's
a backstory here that brought that
person to be who they are and I I want
to be the one that finds out yeah I mean
as I didn't have too many auditions in
high school mm-hmm I guess in New York I
just try to play it the best I can like
yeah yeah I don't know I think I'd
actually think there is a danger in
trying there's as an actor you got to
make choices but there's a danger in
kind of overintellectualizing
what you're doing too much and kind of
saying I need this result to happen or I
want this result to happen or or you
have a fixed idea of what a character is
supposed to be I mean you can play with
it and you can see what the essence of
the character is and what part of the
story the character is at and then you
can try different things like I imagine
this characters a bit like a panther
maybe that's how he moves or maybe this
character this characters like like that
boisterous Texas man I saw the bar the
other night but actually I think you can
get to cut up and backstory I mean I
think there are some decisions that you
have to make but like I think so many
people try to think like what's this
character's favorite color or like you
know what's like like what what made him
cry is a kid and they think like if it's
hinted at in the script or if it's
important then yeah maybe decide that
but I think if it's if you just may
and stuff up I think you can kind of get
caught up in your own head and you can
kind of hypnotize yourself
or your ears just all just psychology
that just is just things you made up
rather than just something that's quite
tangible that's kind of immediate like a
like a set like the whole Panther thing
it's like you know there's a very simple
and recognizable essence to a Panther
you know or like a chicken or whatever
you think your character is so I guess
when I look at the audition like I know
that I'm different and I know that I
don't express emotion or intention in a
way that most people do so and I have to
be aware of that let's say if I'm
playing a clean-cut businessman now I'll
have to change my essence but at the end
of the day I know that it's just me so I
think that'll come across give me an
example of a human Panther if you were a
man in a suit or whatever your attire is
what you're a human Panther in some
sense good example uh hmm I think
because they're very sleek to the way
they move forgot to be really really
specific on this they're calculating
I'll tell you what it's not Michael
Crawford is the original fan of the
Opera if you watch the way he moved I
wasn't born at that time but I've seen
videos of him and I've talked to people
who watched it he moved almost like a
panther like every move that he made was
so fluid and so calculated and he was
just so it's like every muscle in his
body was just so kind of focused on what
was in front of him and he actually he
wore very small shoes were too tight for
him so every step he had to take had to
be very delicate and very precise and
very ginger because that his shoes were
so tight and he chose to do that to make
himself move more you know more
cautiously so he didn't have to acted
interesting do you study a lot of old
movies oh yeah hell hell yeah I think I
think young actors don't watch nearly
enough old performances because they
they're given this idea that it's dated
and yeah maybe some things are different
but I think there's a lot you can learn
from old actors even if the style is
different you can adjust it but yeah I
watched a lot of old movies
what Brando yeah I don't anyone else
James Dean yeah Dean's great I think he
yeah Dean's great I think he had a few
flaws but he's that he's got great very
interesting physicality everything he
does is so reflexive and so spontaneous
and he's just so supple
you know Brando had it very much of
attention about him and Dean was much
more kind of flowing Henry Fonda is a
favorite of mine an old favorite very
unaffected any older actor that was also
an outsider uh well Dean you know he was
a moody teenager and it's kind of the
guy just felt very disconnected from
where he was you know like that's why I
think rebel people still look at that
image of rebel without a cause because
he's just a teenager doesn't know what
he wants to do with his life and doesn't
feel like he has any role models and
Robert Mitchum was quite an outsider you
know he was a first actor arrested for
smoking pot I mean if you look at night
of the hunter that's such a strange
performance which i think is why it
holds up now it was weird then and it's
still weird now so Robert Mitchum is
definitely an outsider actor I think a
female actress I mean I know a Marilyn
Monroe definitely had a sort of a bunny
like facade but I think she was very
bright and intense no yeah she yes great
movement my god if you look at her hips
like you know she's got the great sawing
the hips with Maryland the way she moves
them a little little more recent but I
think Spacek might be my favorite
actress she's got a very unique lot of
grace about Spacek I think a lot
of understanding I look at Badlands you
know just doesn't even feel like a
performance
you